[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
bienvenue dans ça vous regarde
à la une ce soir comment obliger au
télétravail avec l'épidémie qui flambent
l'exécutif appelle les entreprises à le
généraliser au maximum en septembre
seuls 12 % des salariés ont travaillé à
la maison alors pourquoi employeurs et
salariés ne joue pas vraiment le jeu
faut-il rendre le télétravail
obligatoire le peut-on vraiment c'est la
question du grand débat ce soir
jusqu'où ira l'escaladé de la tension
entre paris et ankara ne retombe pas
dans le sillage des déclarations chocs
de gratte-ciel tayyip erdogan après
l'appel au boycott des produits français
le ministre turc de la culture qualifie
je cite charlie hebdo de bâtard en cause
la nouvelle une du journal satirique qui
montre le président turc en slip une
bière à la main on va décrypter tout
cela dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission enfin notre grand témoin ce
soir a du pain sur la planche le plan de
relance qu'il doit faire voter à
l'assemblée semble déjà cadic caduque
l'état at-il les moyens d'absorber un
nouveau choc économique avec ce nouveau
tour de vis le rapporteur général du
budget laurent saint martin avec nous ce
soir voilà donc tout le programme tout
de suite le grand débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs bonsoir le rang
saint-martin masquer ce soir nos invités
le son protocole sanitaire alors c'est
guillaume mérie même les chroniqueurs
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes député la république on marche
du val de marne vous venez de publier un
petit livre qu'on va voir s'afficher à
l'antenne la fabrique de l'impôt chez
alma éditeurs comment faire consentir
les citoyens à l'impôt vous êtes aussi
rapporteur général du budget on va en
parler dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission parce que on se pose la
question la loi de finances pour l'année
prochaine est elle déjà obsolète avec ce
tour de vis d'ampleur qui va être
annoncé je précise d'emblée à nos
téléspectateurs que cette émission est
enregistrée avant les annonces à 20h
d'emmanuel macro à cette heure si on ne
connaît donc pas encore l'ampleur du
confinement qui nous attend sûrement
mais une chose est sûre le président de
la république va demander aux
entreprises de faire encore plus
en matière de télétravail bonsoir benoît
faire bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on
va en parler puisque vous représentez
les drh
c'est vous un qui est en mesure de faire
appliquer des travail dans les
entreprises c'est pas facile vice
président de l'association nationale des
directeurs de ressources humaines m
franck morel est allé également bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes avocat
spécialisé en droit du travail un
représentant des salariés de la cgt
fabrice angeli va nous rejoindre dans
quelques minutes et bonsoir stéphane bon
se remirent ailleurs les fans blakowski
vous connaissez le télétravail vous avez
planché toute la journée le dessous sur
le sujet qu avez-vous compris votre
billet pour démarrer cette émission tout
de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris stéphane ce soir
ben vous l'avez bien si j'ai bien
compris la semaine prochaine je vais
donc grandes chances que je me retrouve
chez moi avec ma femme et trois enfants
mon chien je vais m'en ferney de mon
bureau
et puis on va refaire des chroniques par
skype comme on l'avait fait pendant le
confinement au swing and ça ne fait pas
spécialement plaisir mais que voulez
vous c'est retour de l'événement donc
égale retour du télétravail vous l'avez
dit en tout cas c'est ce que souhaite
elisabeth bordant l'écoutent vous avez
compris que dans le contexte actuel il
faut aller au maximum de ce que l'on
peut faire sur le télétravail
pourquoi vous vous rendrez vous le
rendez pas obligatoire ce titre je crois
que c'est à peu près ce que je suis en
train de dire quand on peut avoir
clairement donné sur un poste où on peut
t'aider travailler il faut télétravail
et si on écoute bien la ministre elle
encourage au télétravail au maximum mais
ça n'est pas obligatoire elle a dit
c'est à peu prêt obligatoire donc c'est
oui voyez ce que dira pas tout à fait en
fait non le retour télétravail c'est
surtout une avant tout une mesure
sanitaire donc c'est pas destinée en
tout cas pour l'instant à s'inscrire
durablement dans la loi c'est surtout
lié aux circonstances d'ailleurs quand
le gouvernement communique veiller sur
la question on peut lire ce qui est
écrit et 10
on doit aller travailler autant que
possible donc ce n'est pas vraiment une
obligation mais en même temps que tout
le monde n'avait pas forcément de très
envie de développer le télétravail en
france par exemple en juin dernier à la
fin du confinement
le patron du medef ce qu'est ce qu'ils
en pensaient du télétravail va regarder
il a dit au parisien il devait ça ne
doit pas devenir la norme le télétravail
vu d'ailleurs n'était pas le seul à dix
jours après qu'ils disent à eybens le
miz de l'économie disait exactement la
même chose figurez-vous ne doit surtout
pas devenir la norme et tous les patrons
ne sont pas hostiles non mais surtout
les patrons ne sont pas aussi ne me
faites pas dire du mal des patrons pas
du tout il naquit qui ont réfléchi à la
question qui ont fait leurs calculs qui
se sont dits en fait c'est super le
télétravail
ça a des gros avantages regarder carlos
tavares patron du constructeur
automobile psa
il trouve ça génial de télétravail en
fait quarante mille personnes en
télétravail
la conséquence est forcément il
rassemble moins besoin de bureaux -
besoin de loyer ça sera l'occasion de
faire des économies n'auriez donc les
patrons eux ils sont pas très bons mais
à la cga la cfdt chez psa on a fait un
sondage en interne et du coup les accus
les salariés étaient inquiets mais
disons si on télétravail on va
s'éloigner en fait on va fragiliser
notre emploi donc
on est là en tout cas ce qu'on constate
c'est que de télétravail est en recul
par rapport au confinement total le
premier confinement bah oui si les
patrons sont méfiants et que les
salariés sont inquiets c'est sûr ça
n'aide pas forcément à se mettre
d'accord donc le détective mans le
télétravail a diminué c'était 17 % de
salariés pendant le continent selon la
dares
à la rentrée il n'y avait plus que 12 %
et les chiffres étaient cités par le
figaro
mais c'est un peu ridicule en fait de
résumer ça ces deux chiffres parce que
c'est extrêmement variées sur le
territoire d'abord en fonction des
métiers on s'en doute bien
alors non on voit forcément les
assurances la banque nous regarde et on
est assis ombret je vais te parler ma
chronique sur skype et puis à d'autres
métiers où c'est moins possible et puis
aussi d une grande disparité sur
l'insulté en france sur le territoire
voyez que en île de france par exemple
jusqu'à 30% de télétravail beaucoup de
ces chaussures bureau c'est nanterre
dans les hauts de france et trois fois
moins difficile de faire des généralités
sur sur ce sujet alors quel est l'avenir
du télétravail pour en savoir plus il
faudra justement le 3 novembre puisque
les méfiants les inquiets vont devoir se
parler pour voir si les patrons et
syndicats dont vouloir se parler pour
faire avancer le dossier en attendant ce
qui est sûr c'est que voilà bah on va
reprendre le télétravail ce qui s'est
passé est-ce que ça dure après le
confinement après l'épidémie
eh ben on va se poser la question merci
beaucoup stéphane benoît sert
l'impulsion télétravail il a été massive
au moment du confinement puis c'est
retombé alors c'est compliqué de faire
le bilan
les fameux 12% dont parlait stéphane ses
12 % des heures travaillées par semaine
des salariés en télétravail je précise
mais pourquoi
certes on alors il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord le sur les chiffres c'est
important parce qu'en réalité pendant
confinement on était à presque 37 % de
gens qui télétravaillent et en france
pendant le confinement sur l'ensemble
des français 87%
donc ça c'est un point quand même
important la seconde chose la france
avant le confinement est un pays en
retard sur le télétravail par rapport
notamment aux pays d'europe du nord
il ya aucune raison pour que après le
confinement elle soit en avance
la seule différence et c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle c'est que certaines
entreprises ont découvert deux choses
dans la douleur parce que vous pas
perdre de vue que quand le confinement a
été déclaré en mars
les entreprises se sont retournées en 48
heures elles ont découvert d'abord que
c'était possible
elles ont une confirmation ce qu'on
savait déjà nous les des halles depuis
longtemps que ça ne dégrade pas la
productivité
mais surtout elles ont découvert que
certains métiers auxquels personne
n'avait pensé qu'ils étaient les
travaillable le sont devenus et nous on
a fait une enquête à un drh en juin
dernier avec le bcg qui montrait ça et
que le télétravail se développera en
france non pas par le nombre de jours
mais par le nombre de métiers type et
métiers relation client où on pensait
que ce n'était pas possible
c'est devenu possible dernier point par
téléphone par skype attention oui
exactement
attention au télétravail haute ou
télétravail il est extrêmement dangereux
pour la cohésion sociale des entreprises
pour le fonction les entreprises c'est
pour ça que les patrons coms et stéphane
blakowski sont pour certains un peu
craintifs parce que ça pose des
problèmes de management parce qu'on
n'est pas habitué à manager ça mais
l'autre raison c'est que l'hybridation
du travail c'est à dire deux jours deux
jours et demi semble être la bonne voie
parce que quand vous êtes à trois jours
vous changer de monde
sauf que deux trois jours c'est
peut-être insuffisant un épidémiologiste
médiatique le professeur comme parce que
lui n'est pas du tout mais alors pas du
tout content du bilan télétravail dans
votre pays vous voulez pas sûr qu il ya
un vrai flottement sur le télétravail
vous avez raison de le souligner moi je
pense qu'on n'aurait jamais dû arrêter
le télétravail notamment incité des gens
abandonner le télétravail
à la reprise après les vacances en
septembre je pense que ça a été une
erreur
il faut rester au télétravail le plus
possible c'est un outil de lutte contre
l'épidémie
maître morel que dit le droit du travail
est-ce qu'on peut obliger un salarié à
être en télétravail déjà la réponse est
dans le contexte spécifique que nous
connaissons oui il ya une disposition
dans le code du travail qui permet dans
les cas de force majeure dans les cas de
crises dans les cas d'épidémie jeunes et
sains et sanitaires effectivement que
nous connaissons de permettre dû mettre
en place le télétravail de manière
directe
ça a été utilisée très largement pendant
le confinement et ça avait été dur est
fait pour ça puisque au moment des
ordonnances de septembre 2010 est des
ordonnances de réforme du code du
travail
ce dispositif avait été allégé et avait
été supprimé le renvoie à un décret qui
n'empêchait l'utilisation donc il a été
possible et il est possible dans le
contexte spécifique que nous le
connaissons encore une fois qui est très
particulier
deux crises sanitaires de mettre en
place le télétravail de manière directe
oui c'est possible
alors pourquoi pourquoi ça n'est pas le
cas alors après je pense qu'on peut
aller ses employeurs au fond n'utilise
pas ce code cet article du code du lot
ont utilisé comme l'a dit benoît sert
tout à l'heure ils l'ont utilisé assez
massivement pendant la période de
confinement puisque le télétravail
lusage du télétravail pendant cette
période a été à peu près x 4 de manière
massive molina valoir en fait à ce
moment là je n'avais pas le choix et ce
qui renvoie effectivement à une question
c'est pourquoi faut-il utiliser plus
largement le télétravail il ya deux
types de raisons à cela
le premier type de raison c'est la
raison pour laquelle il a été
massivement utilisés notamment pendant
le confinement c'est parce que dans un
certain nombre de cas cela permet tout
bêtement de continuer à fonctionner à
l'activité de continuer à fonctionner ça
permet aussi d'éviter des clusters que
son et le brillant type de raisons
effectivement il est sanitaire c'est
parce qu'effectivement c'est aussi une
réponse à la crise sanitaire au fait
d'éviter les interactions sociales et
par rapport à la question de
l'obligation ou de la non obligation en
direction des entreprises est ce qu a
dit la ministre du travail
eh bien je renverrai en fait au même
débat que celui qui s'est développée au
moment du port du masque obligatoire
vous souvenez fin août notification du
protocole sanitaire et dans le protocole
sanitaire et diction d'un principe selon
lequel le port du masque en entreprise
devient obligatoire
la question s'est posée est ce que c'est
vraiment obligatoire puisque c'est écrit
dans un protocole et le juge
administratif est venu répondre à cette
question puisqu'il était saisi début
dire deux choses il est venu dire il
s'agit d'une recommandation mais c'est
une recommandation qui vise à décliner
l'obligation plus général qui pèse sur
l'entreprise d'organiser la prévention
des risques professionnels donc
l'obligation elle est en général sur
l'employeur sur l'entreprise de trouver
les moyens les plus adaptés pour
organiser la prévention des risques
professionnels et l'autre et les
travaillant d'organisation au sein de
l'entreprise et je salue la présence sur
ce plateau de fabrice angèle bonsoir
monsieur vont souvent crétaire
confédérale de la cgt
elle doit être discuté on l'a dit dans
les jours qui viennent parce que tout le
monde a compris qu'on va devoir
davantage td travailler pourquoi les
salariés et les syndicats que vous
n'êtes que vous représentez les sarries
ne pousse pas davantage
au télétravail je vais expliquer
circuler dans la façon dont aujourd'hui
le télétravail se met en place
ce n'est pas du télétravail le
télétravail c'est lié à une organisation
du travail
aujourd'hui on est dans le seul cadre
limité d'une réponse à une crise
sanitaire à une mesure sanitaire qui se
traduit pour les salariés par une
travail à domicile dégradé et toutes les
aurait fait l'arrêt répondre et toutes
les enquêtes le design comme don autant
on à l âge lui confère une majorité de
salariés une très large majorité qui
sont favorables le télétravail pour x
raisons 1 pour x raisons de transport
etc et autant tous tous disent
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils ont vécu au
confinement
c'est un mode dégradé et des risques
d'isolement c'est les risques de
cohabitation dans le temps dans le foyer
salut je le domicile donc ce tri faune m
effectivement aujourd'hui tout à fait si
on doit prendre en compte le télétravail
il faut le faire dans un cadre large
qu'est-ce-qui paquet plusieurs
catégories plusieurs typologies y
compris les complet des mesures
d'urgence mais il faut une cadre général
qui le régissent
c'est effectivement donc la prise en
charge la prise en charge des moyens
tant on a quatre zellal on a en un
confinement à cette mode horde c'est un
mode d'organisation vous plaignez qu'en
france on était en de ça moi je crois
que le travail est de travailler dans
l'urgence hier louis mais oui mais
justement ça peut pas se limiter à
l'actrice anitea c'est la pire des
façons de l'aborder
il est temps et la cgt a fermement
qu'elle pousse on a poussé et de
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui un site au
télétravail n'a pas trop incité jusqu'à
présent les entreprises à négocier un
accord-cadre sur le télétravail ajout
belge dans cette affaire de télétravail
à votre avis les employeurs ou les
salariés moi je crois que tout le monde
joue le jeu depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire et qu'il y avait
effectivement un certain nombre
d'améliorations à faire jour gendre ce
que dit monsieur le télétravail tel que
nous l'avons un petit peu
améliorer et créé pendant la première
phase du confinement est largement
améliorable effectivement il faut créer
des conditions pour que le travail à
domicile par exemple puisse se faire
dans des conditions beaucoup plus
organisés au sein de l'entreprise
ce n'est pas uniquement le monde d'après
la crise sanitaire mais aujourd'hui vous
avez 25 % des connexions entre le fait
de signer devant devant les transpirer
une concertation xavi y avait une
concertation avant les ordonnances à ce
qui a été fait en 2010 est signé par des
organisations syndicales
les cinq représentative dans la cgt et
le patronat les trois nous toise les
passants pour mettre en place à l'hôtel
et des sa et sas haristoy maryse
dégradables dans les relations ça
rappellera toujours mais l'humour
d'urgence il ya deux choses d'abord
rappelé que le droit individuel au
télétravail a été instauré dans la loi à
l'été 2010 est à l'époque on se moquait
pas mal de nous d'ailleurs dans
l'hémicycle en disant que c'était
gadgets etc
on voit bien quand même utilité que cela
peut créer aujourd'hui mans la deuxième
chose c'est que malgré tout si on
regarde les données eurostat la france
avant la crise était pas si en retard
que ça peut-être par rapport à d'autres
pays
4 7 % d'utilisation de télétravail et
que l'europe était à moins de 4% donc
avait déjà cette appétence là le faire
et évidemment la crise comme vous le
dites a très fortement accélérer ce
processus et nous devons sortir de la
crise avec un vrai outil télétravail qui
font que je suis élu du val de marne les
habitants de ma circonscription comme
bien ressortir de cette crise en
utilisant d'inventaire le ténor ou
ramenèrent de l'après crise je vais vous
montrer un reportage vous redonne la
parole juste après les bons duels
elle s'est rendue dans une entreprise de
conseils parisienne pour voir un petit
peu comment ça se mettaient concrètement
en place regardez
pas la peine de chercher dans les locaux
dif keromnes il n'y a personne ou
presque
vous voyez ici on fait pièce et on a mis
sept postes de travail en accompagnant
pour respecter les distances
aujourd'hui il ya de salariés présents
mais quatre autres paires en télétravail
depuis le confinement sa société
spécialisée dans les études de marché
s'est converti au télétravail et
pourtant ce n'était pas évident avec
deux salariés fait qu'il fêtait déjà la
règle mais pour le reste non et personne
ne l'avait expérimenté moi le premier
j'étais même plutôt à distance du
télétravail j'avais le sentiment que la
vie de l'entreprise c'était dans les
locaux de l'entreprise contre un on a
juste et adapter les choses aujourd'hui
ça fonctionne très bien c'est le cas
pour jean christophe depuis les débuts
du confinement il a adopté le
télétravail est de fait repenser son
appartement
c'est peut-être pas l'idéal puisque j'ai
dû adapter mon salon pour pour
travailler pour faire du télétravail sa
demande le soir évidemment de tout de
tout remettre en place
mais voilà je me débrouille comme je
peux et au final on va dire que ça ça
fonctionne
il y trouve même pas mal davantage et se
dit plus productifs il ya moins de
stress parce qu'on est dans un univers
ben qui est intime on est plus efficace
dans le sens où il n'y a pas tout ce
temps
perdu on va dire dans les transports en
commun ses collègues ils les voient
principalement en visioconférence salué
valérie oui ça va j'ai également une
salle après midi lors de la réunion
d'accord ce qui manque le plus à l'une
comme un autre c'est l'émulation et
surtout le lien social
alors un jour par semaine au moins ils
se rendent sur leur lieu de travail
c'est la société qu'il impose la journée
au travail déjà c'est quand même moyen
de socialiser d'échangés d'être mieux
ainsi quelquefois haussier je n'ai pas
de parler d'autre chose que du travail
de voile avec ses collègues ses sept
mois à la maison ont convaincu jean
christophe et contre toute attente ils
ont aussi bouleversé les habitudes de
son patron et de sa famille nous vivions
en région parisienne le confinement
était pour nous en bretagne et
et ça nous a fait prendre conscience de
plein de choses de la capacité surtout
de travailler à distance et de travail
depuis un autre lieu et du coup
aujourd'hui nous vivons en juillet en
bretagne il ne vient plus que deux à
trois jours par semaine à paris et il
songe même à trouver des nouveaux locaux
plus petits pour faire des économies
voilà on voit que le télétravail
bouleverse et donne des idées de
changement de vie aux français mais pour
revenir sur la crise qui nous faire
voilà la crise sanitaire le gouvernement
si le télétravail ne suis pas va devoir
sortir le carnet de chèques pour le
chômage partiel c'est ça qu'il veut
éviter parce que les gens pourront plus
sortir
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait non pas tout à
fait parce que si vous vous souvenez
pendant la période de mars
la prise en charge de chômage partiel
n'était réservé qu'à ceux dont le métier
n'était pas télétravail parce que dans
le débat qu'on a sur le télétravail en
ce moment et qu'on a beaucoup depuis
quelques mois on oublie quand même que
vous avez à peu près 60% des salariés
qui n'ont pas accès du fait de leur
métier cette part va sans doute se
réduire dans le temps il faut un peu de
temps quand même pour réorganiser les
choses
vous citiez le cas de psa qui est
extrêmement volontariste là dessus ça
concerne qu'une partie de ses salariés
d'une part et d'autre part psa avait
déjà une histoire du télétravail et ça
rejoint un point que vous aviez évoqué
monsieur il franco elle aussi évoqué
c'est que vous ne resterez pas des
nouveaux modes de travail dans
l'entreprise comme ça parce que ça
impacte de management ça impacte
l'organisation vous avez des gens qui ne
veulent pas aller en télétravail
vous avez des gens qui ont besoin comme
c'était un dicton quand on est en crise
où toute façon si ce soir le président
la république annonce un confinement
général y aura pas le choix
les 40 % de français qui étaient en
télétravail en mars le retrouvons en
télétravail c'est en tiendrez 113-110
les entreprises soutient et ça nous on
dit que là ce qui nous fait ce qui prime
pour la cgt c'est la santé des salariés
et des travailleurs disent même dans le
passé oui à débat parce qu'il n'ya pas
que le que le télétravail pour assurer
donc pour assurer la santé des salariés
et tout n'est pas travailler là je suis
presque on a aussi une vision un petit
peu d'un le terme de microcosme parisien
le bureau d'études est ici de sieste de
sièges donc le centre où 250 et vous
venez de ma région s'attendent à un
accent la provence régions du sud ont
appelé comme ça aujourd'hui
pendant le confinement il n'y avait
uniquement que 10% malgré les salariés
qui étaient en télétravail pourquoi
parce que réseau tpe artisanat commerce
donc voilà il faut voir la halle
d'attentât contre nancy on peut dire que
là où se dire être le plus renflouées
les grandes métropoles on a vu la carte
présentée stéphane tout à l'heure le
télétravail doit être encouragée avec
les partenaires du palio porte quel prix
mais bon on est d'accord pour fixer une
carte vous avez les deux manières de
fêter le travail que vous avez un accord
si vous avez une charte
une charte est pas d'accord une charte
c'est l'ancien charge avancée ce qui
décida rédige et elle n'est pas obligée
de passer par un accord aujourd'hui la
loi ne le prévoit pas on verra pour
l'avenir je sais que certains syndicats
le demande mais pour le moment c'est pas
le cas quand on regarde les accords qui
existent aujourd'hui mots j'ai toujours
gardé parce que j'en connais un paquet
ils prévoient tous évidemment la prise
en charge des moyens de travail par
l'entreprise a donné au sahara et
pourquoi parce que quand vous êtes en
télétravail vous êtes sous le régime du
contrat de travail et l'entreprise à
l'obligation de vous fournir les moyens
de travailler c'est d'ailleurs ça posait
un problème en mars que vous entretenez
vous n'avez pas d'ordinateur portable il
fallait acheter
donc après vous avez la sphère des
négociants assez largement négocier je
voudrais le site hélas que le ministère
du travail a fait paraître il y à
quelques semaines quelque chose qui fait
paraître tous les ans qui est toujours
très intéressant qui le bilan annuel de
la négociation collective et dans ce
bilan annuel de la négociation
collective on relève quoi on relève que
depuis les trois dernières années le
nombre d'accords collectifs d'entreprise
qui traite du télétravail a été en
augmentation assez importante à ces
croissante évidemment à l'heure où on se
parle nous n'avons pas les chiffres pour
l'année 2020 mais on peut faire le pari
sans prendre trop de risques de se
tromper que ce nombre va continuer à
augmenter et comme l'a dit benoît sert
effectivement on a deux possibilités on
a l'accord collectif d'entreprise ou la
charte et moi je suis persuadé on l'a vu
à travers la question des protocoles en
matière de protection de la santé de la
sécurité
on peut tout à fait concilier d'une part
l'urgence nécessitant une réactivité
extrême et nécessitant la mise en place
de mesures assez rapidement avec le fait
de faire vivre le dialogue social et
avec le fait de gagnant gagnant
je crois martin donc je crois je crois
que ça serait une grave erreur que de ne
pas faire confiance aux partenaires
sociaux pendant la période de la crise
comme s'il y avait une urgence pendant
laquelle on ne pouvait pas faire
confiance au dialogue social et il
fallait imposer par le seul protocole
sanitaire un certain nombre de choses et
que après la prise on verra et les
partenaires sociaux prendront le relais
non je crois au contraire qu'il ya un
momentum extrêmement intéressant pour
que les partenaires sociaux se mettent
tous deux se seraient ils sur le
télétravail mais pas que d'ailleurs je
les gouvernements il faut que le
dialogue social vif pendant la crise de
manière plus large que ce serait une
erreur que le gouvernement au fond sorte
le bâton et farce une forme de chantage
aux entreprises en disant attention si
vous ne faites pas je parle de la crise
sanitaire et du temps présent de
l'urgence si vous ne faites pas de
télétravail mais j'ai des moyens au fond
je ne voudrais pas je ne vous
soutiendrai pas de chômage partiel
garanti
ça serait possible de saint martin à
viège vous est très important mais je
pense que vous n'ignorez pendant la
crise sanitaire
je peux vous le dire jamais le dialogue
social était aussi mais bien se lancer
un temps dans les entreprises il ya eu 9
mai l'accord de reprise activités entre
eux mais ça prouve bien que lorsqu'on
laisse le dialogue social sur ces sujets
là au plus près du terrain avec les
entreprises avec un présentant du
personnel au regard de la réalité de
l'entreprise ça marche
ce qu'on nous dit nous l andrh lancé un
pack à roisin c'est qu'on n'est pas
favorable
dans ce genre de choses à des
négociations d'en haut qui viennent
freiner le momentum que des cartons
parce que je pense que télétravail va
devenir est un des éléments en
complément et de mesures d'ampleur on
est prêt non pour aller dans le sens de
ce que vient dire benoît sert je pense
qu'il serait si aisément le fait que le
cadre applicable et était très souple
issus des ordonnances de 17 était très
souple a été un des facteurs explicatifs
qui a permis l'explosion du nombre de
télétravailleurs le dialogue de gaz
fructueux qui n'a jamais été aussi
intense que pendant cette crise ou même
temps
interne je conteste pas fructueux sas et
d'autres d'autres mesures parce que si
on prend si on élargit le sujet sur les
accords par exemple donc d'activité
partielle de longue durée ou ou sur les
zapper et donc sur les apc d'accord de
performance collective
on voit bien que y compris lé syndicat
signataire et nous on enseigne aussi
donc on peut se mettre dedans
les syndicats signataires disent tous
que c'est quelque part contraint le
couteau sous la gorge parce qu'on ne
peut pas faire autrement parce que c'est
sinon la fermeture de l'entreprise etc
etc
la peur de perte de l'emploi donc voilà
je je nuancerais sur wii extension du
nombre d'accords
est ce que ces désaccords vraiment
consenti que cette chose mais nous je le
retiens encore une fois on l'a on allait
travailler en 2010 est donc le
gouvernement revienne dessus avec tous
les partenaires sociaux donc un cadre un
cadre qui permet d'appliquer les accords
locaux
parce que ce que je rejoins goyer c'est
que effectivement telle adaptation
d'être locales mais il faut des
garanties nationales sur la prise en
compte
combien de temps peut être des questions
toutes simples à vous poser ce débat qui
qui s'achève est ce que ge a pas un
soupçon de l'employeur sur le
télétravail est ce qu'on n'a pas
toujours tendance à penser que le
salarié chez lui eh ben ils se tournent
les pouces un peu plus que au bureau
franchement pour répondre à votre
question il ya un ingrédient en tout cas
essentiel dans l'organisation du
télétravail c'est évidemment la
confiance parce que évidemment vous êtes
éloignés l'un de l'autre et donc en
matière de gestion du temps de travail
en matière de suivi de la charge de
travail en matière d'organisation des
temps collectifs
évidemment tout ça est très différent
les logiciels de surveillance a
notamment dans les ordinateurs des
caméras c'est l'entité mix cette
question de la confiance et cette
question de la bonne my entre d'une part
l'autonomie laisser aux télétravailleurs
et d'autre part le fait de poser un
certain nombre de règles
c'est aussi un plaidoyer pour négocier
ou pour mettre en place une charte qui
sécurise tout le monde
laurent saint martin le monde d'après
c'est un train un télétravail en toute
confiance sans son suspicion mais je
crois que beaucoup d'entreprises
beaucoup de managers se sont rendus
compte que l'obligation de résultat
était plus importante que l'obligation
de moyens et qui effectivement cela
passe par un degré de confiance
renforcée moi je crois qu'effectivement
beaucoup de managers intermédiaires qui
n'a
beaucoup l'habitude de cela l'on
découvert pendant la première phase de
la crise et je pense qu'un bon acquis en
un mot le management à la française il
est fondé sur le présentéisme et ça
qu'il faut changer les portes claquent
dernière tu dis moi tu sais quand même
patronat rétrograde et la question vous
avez raison de la pose et la raisonner
par rapport aux organisations patronales
je vais préciser le medef en premier
c'est la discussion de paritaire a mis
en avant qu'en fait c'étaient ces cas et
une libéralité ne liberté consentis aux
travailleurs et donc oui pour le
patronat alors je parle pas du chef
d'entreprise à 60 ans je parle au niveau
d'organismes syndicaux
donc au niveau du medef oui à une
considération que il y à quelques pas
royal il ya un manque de confiance à
s'arrêter là mais on a quand même en
senti sur ce plateau qui a beaucoup de
consensus que le dialogue est ouvert
je vous donne cette information c'est
pas du tout la france twitter envisage
le télétravail à vis de ces dizaines de
milliers de salariés
ça ne sera pas le cas dans notre pays ça
ne sera pas la norme merci survenu sur
le plateau de lcp laurent saint martin
vous restez avec nous va s'interroger à
présent sur le plan de relance est il
déjà dépassé avec ce tour de vis
d'ampleur attendu ce soir
tout de suite les réponses
alors ce budget ce budget le rang saint
martin que vous allez faire voter à
l'assemblée nationale est-il caduque
pour le savoir thomas des prêts qui fait
sa chronique tous les jours l assemblée
dans cette émission est allé à la
rencontre de vos collègues de la
commission des finances n'est ce pas
thomas vous leur avez posé la question
oui exactement myriam depuis près d'un
mois les députés examinent le plan de
relance ce fameux plan à 100 milliards
d'euros
mais sera-t-il suffisant à absorber le
choc économique de la deuxième vague
certains députés sont très sceptiques
sur la question je vous raconte tout ça
alors l'assemblée depuis plusieurs
semaines on débat du projet de loi de
finances de l'année à 2021 du plan de
relance qui a été préparé il y a
plusieurs semaines maintenant à une
époque où il n'y avait a pas de deuxième
vague pas de couvre-feu pas même de
reconfirmer mais alors ces nouvelles
annonces menace-t-elle ce projet de loi
de finances leur hôtel caduque
on a posé la question aux députés ils
sont très divisés sur la question
madame la députée est ce que le budget
2021 et déjà caduque oui oui j'ai le
sentiment qu'il ya pas de pilote dans
l'avion et je pense que les français en
sont conscients
déjà nous nous considérions qu'il tapé à
côté là très clairement c'est si on a
des annonces de mesures plus
restrictives sur la vie sociale et la
vie économique
on va avoir des secteurs très en
souffrance on va avoir encore du chômage
donc là effectivement il va falloir
maintenant aller vers les mesures
d'urgence qui sont absolument
nécessaires autant sur la première vague
honnêtement c'est difficile c'est
difficile ça vous tombe dessus
vous n'êtes pas près autant aujourd'hui
on a l'impression qu'entre la première
vague et cette deuxième vague
il n'y a pas eu d'anticipation rien n'a
bougé c'est comme si le gouvernement
n'avait pas cru finalement à cette
deuxième vague peut pas tout anticipé à
la vente mais rien ne nous empêche de
faire évoluer les choses avec les
décisions qui pourraient être prises ce
soir sera évidemment amené à amplifier
le soutien un certain nombre de corps de
métiers de ce secteur ça me pose
absolument aucun problème jusqu'à la mi
décembre
nous serons pleinement attaché à
travailler sur le
le projet de loi de finances sur le
budget de la nation et nous pourrons à
ce moment là apporter toutes les
modifications on a le sentiment d'être
toujours en train de courir après les
dégâts aujourd'hui causés par cette
pandémie au plan économique mais que
l'état ne s'est pas adapté dans sa façon
de prévoir et d'anticiper ce virus comme
l'a dit le président on va vivre avec
pendant encore de nombreux mois donc le
budget 2021 a pris en compte cette
donnée est extrêmement importante et
nous allons accompagner les entreprises
à la fois pour sauver celle à qui on
demande des efforts particuliers et pour
accompagner celle qui continuent leur
développement pour être les locomotives
de demain voilà madame je n'ai pas
réussi à mettre d'accord les députés
mais peut-être que votre invité lui y
arrivera on va lui poser la question de
suite n'est pas déjà caduc ce budget
2021 la réponse est non
on a dit depuis le début que c'était un
budget que nous devions construire et
beaucoup d'humilité à la fois sur les
prévisions macroéconomiques de
croissance de déficit d'embêtements mais
aussi par rapport aux mesures que nous
mettions en place mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que le budget que nous votons la
france en a besoin
ils entendaient roland aujourd'hui le
temps est à nouveau à l'urgence au
soutien à tous ses secteurs stratégiques
qui vont vraiment peut-être disparaître
est ce que c'est c'est calibrée est ce
qu il est pas un peu trop comment dire
décalé ce plan de relance aujourd'hui la
crise que nous vivons appelle deux types
de réponses différentes à l'appel types
de réponses d'abord soutien d'urgence
tous les secteurs d'activité qui ont été
engagés dont certains ont continué à
l'être pendant l'été on a l'impression
que à partir de déconfinement tout le
monde a pu redémarrer c'est pas vrai je
rappelle qu'on a eu aussi des mesures
d'urgence pour les discothèques pour les
voyagistes pour tout un secteur
d'activité qui était encore contraint
par malheureusement secteur mesure entre
des le saurons pas avant les annonces de
ce soir vont conforter le fait que
l'état de continuer à être au chevet des
entreprises des salariés qui sont
justement empêché par des conditions
administratives a des potentiels
supplémentaires des dépenses
supplémentaires qu'il faudra intégrer ne
se sont jamais arrêté même en quoi elles
ne se sont jamais arrêtés depuis le
début de la crise donc ça c'est la
première réponse le soutien l'urgent
et en parallèle il serait coupable de ne
pas préparer la relance justement parce
que d'autres secteurs d'activité
continue repartent déjà et continuera en
repartir après les mesures de
restriction annoncées ce soir nous
votons au budget pour l'année 2000 21
heureusement que nous ne devons pas
partir du principe que l'accusé avait
été instruit se rassurent une salve
allègrement vécu dans un confinement
généralisée l'année 2021 ça doit être
l'année de la reprise ça doit être
l'année de la reprise donc nous avons
toujours fonctionné sur ses deux jambes
le soutien est l'urgence pour le court
terme pour les hélas rolland président
m'a dit mais bien sûr nous aimerions
garder la révision 3 ans à vivre avec
cette dualité la 10 % il ya du soutien
et il ya de la reprise
en même temps c'est très particulier la
crise que nous vivons puisque nous avons
mis sous cloche si vous passez
l'expression à la fois notre économie
mais aussi la consommation des ménages
pour faire redémarrer à la fois la
production l'investissement l'emploi la
consommation des ménages
il nous faut en parallèle et pour cent
de croiser soutien et faire de la
prévision sur laquelle est construite ce
budget de relance et pas trop optimistes
les % deuxième vague 8% de croissance
c'était la projection ce que je vous dis
c'est que ces chiffres là pour le coup
ils ne sont pas intéressants puisque
nous ne savons pas comment l'année 2000
21 ans va précisément se dérouler au
niveau de la crise sanitaire qui
elle-même fait dépendre les conditions
de la crise économique et sociale donc
peu me chaut le niveau de croissance
exact de 2021 ce que je sais c'est que
nous devons voter man des mesures
budgétaires pour préparer la france en
2021 et donc il y aura en même temps des
mesures de soutien pour les ménages
aussi faut-il le rappeler nous soutenons
aussi les particuliers pas uniquement
les entreprises
et puis préparer les emplois de demain
et tout cela est vraiment et ça vous
vous y engager cela dit on le fait on le
tiendra croire parce que dans les gares
dans le budget en regardant le budget
vous verrez qu'il n'ya pas deux ans
pendant ce budget ce qui est vrai par
contre c'est que si vous dépensez que
vous n'augmentez pas les impôts il n'y a
pas de recette magique
la dernière inconnue de l'équation c'est
l'endettement ça c'est vrai donc la
réponse elle vous dit
pour l'instant on peut se permettre et
la france a fait un choix de
responsabilité comme honnêtement tous
les pays du monde c'est celle de
l'endettement et il faut le dire en
europe la banque centrale européenne a
joué un rôle
extrêmement important dans
l'accompagnement de l'endettement des
pays comme ceux de la france restent en
haut des en rachetant de nos obligations
sur le marché secondaire et c'est
nécessaire parce que sans endettement
nous ne saurions pas à les faire face au
coût que représente aujourd'hui et le
soutien et la relance faut-il le
rappeler que nous sommes quand même dans
un ordre de grandeur de plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros
or le budget de l'état annuel on est un
peu plus de 400 milliards d'euros
donc ces centaines de milliards d'euros
qui doivent être mis en plus du budget
normal de l'état
vous comprendrez bien qu'on ne va pas
demander aux français de télé poche et
donc oui ça demande de l'endettement qui
devra lui être remboursé s'élève à
suivre évidemment minute par minute ce
débat budgétaire qui avec cette crise
sanitaire est forcément bouleversé vous
restez avec nous ça va vous intéresser
un nouveau rendez vous à présent
françois durpaire contrat du repère qui
va nous accompagner tous les soirs dans
sévères jusqu'à l'élection américaine
j - 7 c'est parti l'élection c'est mardi
prochain
ça semble incroyablement bien je suis en
train de vous sourire oui on sait pas
très bien ce petit masque alors de quoi
nous parlez vous ce soir alors d'une
phrase prononcée par trump qui a 24
heures on était dans le michigan
donc sur le terrain parce que trump pas
de masque ça continue pas de
distanciation sociale des grands
meetings et puis il a dit cette phrase
qui paraît assez invraisemblable on
écoute on n'a pas cette phrase on m'a
dit on en régie qui dit moi je vous la
raconte t elle pas vous imitez de
dommages
donald trump 10 10 3 3 semaines joe
biden est élu et joe biden et x guns
east shot et châtillon le
on lui tire dessus etc kamala harris qui
le remplace alors là évidemment c'est
une sorte de prédiction et sinon ça veut
dire que en fait il ya une ambiguïté
seyant le voit il est là la passion
l'entente va pas pouvoir l'entendre à
l'entendre mais en tout cas il est en
train de dire quoi il est en train de
dire qu'effectivement joe biden pourrait
disparaître de la surface de la planète
il ya une ambiguïté quand même en
anglais parce que shot en anglais ça
peut vouloir dire il est magique où tu
ça peut vouloir dire abattu mais ça peut
vouloir dire il est simplement fou tu
peux ça ait lieu parce qu'il est sait
alors ce qu'il a voulu dire on sait pas
hors de gaza fait polémique
il ya un double sens dans cette phrase
est ce que c'est un appel à la violence
ou est-ce que c'est simplement parce
qu'il est la dernière important oui ce
qui est important de dire c'est une
chose c'est que eh bien il veut mettre
l'accent soit kamala harris l'un est
trop vieux donc c'est kamala harris la
socialiste la communiste celle qui est
proche de bernie sanders qui va le
remplacer
et la deuxième chose c'est que la donne
un train puis à 3 fois moins d'argent
dans les caisses républicaine que dans
les caisses démocrate et ça c'est quand
même plutôt rare donc ça veut dire que
joe biden est chez lui il met des pubs
30 secondes vous savez c'est très très
cher les bleus américaine et lui l'objet
d'aller sur le terrain pour se faire de
la publicité gratuite parce
qu'évidemment publicité gratuite ça veut
dire la presse sauf que la bresse elle
est pas très très gentille
pour le président parce qu'elle dit quoi
parce qu'elle dit que continuer ses
meetings
c'est menacer la vie des américains
record de kovy de la semaine dernière
vendredi dernier plus de 80 mille cas en
un jour et une en une étude qui montre
que si on avait porté les masses comme
on le fait aujourd'hui
depuis le début du confinement on aurait
économisé la vie de cent mille
américains à de petits sombre en
perspective d'autres c'est tout pour 2
désolé
le masque est mon frasier demain on se
retrouve de toute façon demain vous
j'imagine vous suivez jour après jour
cette campagne oui à double titre
d'abord parce que c'est toujours une
campagne que les français aiment suivre
de façon assidue et puis nous avons
aussi des intérêts la france à l'issue
de cette campagne là j'en prends un
exemple la taxe sur les services
numériques la taxe gaffe à ne verra pas
tout à fait le même futur en fonction
d'une rédaction de donald trump ou de
l'élection de dubaï d'un gang à votre
avis non non il peut encore gagner dans
notre homme je balaie les sondages je
crois que tout est encore possible avec
ce système très particulier des
élections américaines sur gaffe à vous
avez maintenant un nouvel allié qui
s'attelle l'état américain et 11 états
américains plus l'état fédéral qui
attaquent en justice s'il vous plaît
google tout simplement merci françois
est désolé pour le petit centre à tous
demain on va passer à présent à notre
décryptage pour terminer cette émission
ce décryptage qui nous emmène ce soir du
côté d'ankara depuis l'assassinât atroce
du professeur samuel pas tirer de cette
hyper dogan multiples provocations et
intimidation pour la deuxième fois il a
contesté la santé mentale des manuels
macro alors à quoi joue le président
turc
réponse tout de suite
jusqu'où ira l'escaladent avant
d'accueillir nos invités les clés pour
comprendre ce nouveau moment d'extrême
tension entre paris et ankara
la nouvelle une de charlie hebdo paru ce
matin caricaturant le président turc a
relancé les hostilités clément père
recep tayyip erdogan en slip bière à la
main soulevant la robe d'une femme
voilée la une du dernier charlie hebdo
n'a pas franchement fait rire la
présidence turque réponses sûr twitter
du chef de presse d'ankara la campagne
anti musulmans du président français
macron porte ses fruits
nous condamnons la volonté méprisable de
cette publication de répandre son
racisme culturel et sa haine
ce même responsable promet une réponse
judiciaire et diplomatique le ministre
de la culture lui tombe dans l'insulté
charlie hebdo vous êtes des bâtards vous
êtes des fils de chienne l'outrance
verbale est une marque de fabrique chez
recep erdogan
lundi déjà le président turc ed rapp au
moment d'évoquer le sort des musulmans
d'europe une campagne de lynchage
semblable à celle contre les juifs
d'europe avant la deuxième guerre
mondiale est en train d'être menées
contre les musulmans
derrière ces violentes saillie se
dessine une stratégie politique se poser
en grands chefs du monde musulman qu'il
veut apparaître comme le meilleur
défenseur des intérêts de l'islam les
intérêts des musulmans contre ce qu'ils
présentent comme des agressions
systématiques de la part des puissances
occidentales dont il ya un jeu là de
politique extérieure c'est qu'il veut se
poser comme le leader du monde musulman
je pense qu'ils se trompent totalement
parce que justement dans lé monde arabe
je pense que pas grand monde n'a envie
de passer sous la direction sous
l'hégémonie de la turquie alors recep
erdogan sultan en carton-pâte son appel
au boycott des produits français n'a pas
eu grand effet et derrière les images
d'une poignée de manifestants turcs anti
charlie se cache une réalité plus
nuancée
les outrances du président sont loin de
faire l'unanimité dans son pays
pour faire très attention entre l'effet
grossissant les félons qui peut exister
pau de tel ou tel appel de telle ou
telle déclaration visant au boycott et
la réalité des faits je pense que
l'immense majorité des turcs comme
l'immense majorité des peuples arabes
dans les pays avoisinants ne sont
aujourd'hui pas préoccupé par cet appel
au boycott ils ont d'autres rêves
questions économiques politiques
sanitaires pandémique à régler dans ce
contexte houleux le quai d'orsay a
appelé les ressortissants français de
turquie à la prudence
surtout si le football s'en mêle le
paris saint germain est ce soir à
istanbul
or affronter bazac échir un club repris
en 2014 par l'entourage de recep erdogan
bonsoir antoine basbous
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes le fondateur de
l'observatoire des pays arabes
et vous allez dialoguer ce soir avec
marc semo bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes journaliste au monde
rédacteur en chef adjoint des pages
débats idée vous connaissez très bien la
turquie pays vous avez été correspondant
pendant des années jusqu où ira
l'escaladé est ce que toutes ces
outrances verbales
on voit encore aujourd'hui avec le
ministre de la culture turque vous ont
surpris antoine basbous
non monsieur erdogan est un habitué du
fait et sa politique intérieure comme
étrangère est fondée sur les excès c'est
ainsi qu'il mobilisera pour pulsât
population sa clientèle qu'il fait
diversion aussi par rapport aux vrais
sujets qui préoccupent les turcs en ce
moment et puis en fait il a trouvé un
vide devant lui avec la l'abandon de
monsieur trempe de la politique
internationale
avec l'affaiblissement de l'otan la
mollesse de l'otan donc monsieur erdogan
s'est retrouvé devant un vide qui
l'attend est de remplir la libye à la
syrie à l'irak en passant par la
méditerranée orientale et récemment par
leur haut karabakh
bref il se déploie sur tous ces fronts
sans que personne ne vienne lui dire
stop sauf peut-être monsieur poutine qui
par une fois
rappelé à l'ordre en abattant quelques
avions turcs et encore il ya deux jours
en l'envoyant ses bombardiers frappé un
camp de mercenaires syrien que monsieur
erdogan entraîner dans le nom de la
série pour les envoyer dans le haut-nkam
alors on va déplier cette stratégie
parce qu'elle n'est pas nouvelle cette
stratégie d'erdogan de montrer sa
puissance de se présenter un peu en chef
des musulmans en tout cas une sorte de
pas l'islamisme comme ça un peu à la
poutine de façon lui avec avec la russie
c'est pas nouveau non c'est pas nouveau
alors ensuite ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'une des raisons de la popularité vers
2 alors qu'ils aient bien érodé mais qui
existe à et comme depuis 18 ans au
pouvoir
c'est que c'est un leader populiste qui
manie le verbe alors c'est assez
fascinant les discours d'ardoyne c'est
un mélange de mots de la rue de meaux de
la mosquée ça change ça a changé sur le
le langage politique habituelle de la
fesse politique turque c'est une des
raisons de sa popularité
et dans cette logique là à voir un
ennemi pouvoir polémiquer avec quelqu'un
c'est pain bénit cannes où les
précédentes alors c'est antoine basbous
à l'écran bon pour rappeler des exemples
précis elle avait traité angela merkel
de nazis parce qu'on avait interdit ces
meetings en allemagne il s'adresse
toujours en tutoyant les autres leaders
étrangers donc là aussi quand même
énorme
est-ce que militaires aussi ça fait
partie de la rhétorique mais si vous
voulez quand vous polémiquer avec lui
quand vous le comparez à poutine voici
jean ping si vous voulez c'est pain
bénit là aussi il est magnifié il est
mis au rang des plus grands acteurs de
la scène internationale et lui son agent
d'un lit double il ya un agenda de
politique intérieure c'est à dire
il joue sur un nationalisme qui est réel
et en plus en partie ya un certain
nombre de raisons d day d'espira sionnel
dans les exigences turques que y compris
son électorat et y compris l'opposition
à demain et puis de l'autre côté il ya
cette guerre aujourd'hui au sein du camp
sunnite au moyen-orient qui oppose d'un
côté pour faire simple
l'arabie saoudite et émirats arabes unis
l'egypte de l'autre les pays proches des
frères musulmans la turquie et le qatar
et donc il est dans cette surenchère
parce que vous remarquerez que dans
cette crise y compris par rapport aux
caricatures l'arabie saoudite
le cas les émirats arabes unis et
l'egypte reste extrêmement discret donc
lui il a le monopole du verbe haut
niveau du monde musulman pour dire
regardez ils insultent le prophète etc
donc c'est de la pure démagogie c'est
extrêmement populiste ça marche à fond
je pense que ce qu'il faut faire c'est
surtout ne pas rentrer dans son jeu
alors est ce que ça marche en tout cas
est ce que ça marche chez lui en turquie
est ce qu'il est soutenu dans son pays
on va rejoindre et je vous donne tout de
suite la parole antoine basbous juste
après avoir besoin de tout de suite
ludovic de foucault en duplex d'istanbul
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté ce
duplex tout est le correspondant de
france 24 en turquie la rue turc soutien
tels red tails
erdogan dans cette surenchère verbale
contre emmanuel macron bonsoir non pas
vraiment on voit des images qui viennent
d'autres pays musulmans avec des
rassemblements très important ce n'est
pas du tout le cas ici en turquie ait eu
quelques manifestations dans le pays
quelques petites manifestations à
istanbul qui ont vraiment peiné à
mobiliser d'ailleurs la plupart du temps
c'est même pas des turcs qui sont
présents mais des syriens de turquie qui
sont extrêmement pro première doit donc
moi vivant à istanbul j'ai pas vraiment
l'impression qu'il ya une grande
différence par rapport à d'habitude ou
vraiment très peur en revanche quand on
parle à des turcs qui ont l'expérience
de la france soit qu'ils ont la double
nationalité soit qu'ils y ont vécu eux
ont plus de véhémence ou de ressentiment
à l'égard de la france et nous disent
que si la france est toujours aussi
prompte à défendre ses valeurs défendre
la liberté d'expression défendre charlie
hebdo combattre le terrorisme elle est
beaucoup moins prompte à lutter contre
un autre problème qui est d'ailleurs au
coeur des difficultés qu'ils aient les
discriminations dont sont victimes les
communautés musulmanes dans la société
française et le boycott des produits
groupe français en turquie à istanbul à
vous êtes c'est suivi ou pas non c'est
passé pas suivi je suis encore aller
chez carrefour tout à l'heure il ya
toujours autant de monde j'ai demandé au
vendeur si il écoulé moins de vache qui
rit ou de kiri ils savaient même pas que
c'était des produits français
quand je vais dans les teckels c'est à
dire les épiceries qui vende
ils vendent de l'alcool et je demande au
vendeur de bière 6,6 boycottent les
bières françaises il éclate de rire de
toutes façons les produits d'importation
sont toujours un peu plus cher les
produits français en particulier et la
situation économique étant ce qu'elle
est en turquie ça change pas grand chose
pour le consommateur tueur que l'on bat
mais ce qui est intéressant avec cette
affaire de boycott c'est que ça a permis
à l'opposition turque de se réveiller
parce que quand le président turc se
drape dans son costume de piliers de
l'islam sunnite de leader de la oumma la
communauté musulmane mondiale de
protecteur des musulmans opprimés du
monde entier même si parle peu des
ouïghours en chine entre parenthèses
c'est très difficile pour l'opposition
est sûre en turquie de l'attaqué parce
que ça voudrait dire qu'elle se retrouve
du côté des ennemis de l'islam
dans un pays aussi pratiquant que la
turquie c'est impossible en revanche
cette affaire d'appels au boycott lui
donne des munitions et là du coup depuis
depuis cette cet appel au boycott lancé
par le président turc des voix s'élèvent
dans l'opposition pour dire mais alors
attendez si vous appeler au boycott des
produits français ce que ça veut dire
que vous allez renoncer à vos airbus
présidentiel en parlant à au président
turc
ou alors est ce que ça veut dire que la
première dame minear douanes va renoncer
à son sac hermès à 40000 euros qui a
fait tellement parlé dans la presse
d'opposition turquie si ici on à erdogan
dans le bayou mythique actuellement en
turquie
merci beaucoup merci du devis que
foucault d'avoir été en direct depuis
istanbul avec moi antoine basbous
elle a des visées intérieure au fond
cette cette surenchère vers la verbal
ces intimidations c'est avant tout pour
redorer une image à l'intérieur du pays
politique et par tienne crise économique
aussi crois qu'il y à trois dimensions
il ya la dimension intérieure
il ya aussi la dimension panislamique ce
parce que erdogan veut se hisser au rang
de qualifs le défendeur du prophète
celui qui va être le leader du monde
sunnite
il y en a pas actuellement alors qu'il
n'est pas mais généralement ça vient de
deux mondes arabe et puis surtout il
attire la lumière les projecteurs et
alors il devient la leader international
et puis avec cette polarisation il se
fraye
un passage pour avoir un statut
international c'est une langue arabe est
ce que dans certains pays arabes
on l'a vu en syrie en libye on l'a vu au
bangladesh brûlent le drapeau français
depuis la publication des caricatures et
qu'on crie vive erdogan s'est pas pour
les beaux yeux d'erdogan c'est pour
parce qu'il ya une émotion qu'il a
suscitées le prophète du simplisme c'est
de la démagogie c'est du populisme et
parfois ça peut marcher
généralement les plus grandes
manifestations pour contre les
caricatures il ya quelques années ça
s'était passé dans le pays le plus
pauvre et le plus reculés du monde
islamique s'était ayaman on voyait des
dizaines de milliers de femmes bâché qui
manifestaient dans la rue on ne savait
pas pourquoi elle manifestait elle non
plus mais on leur proposait un sandwich
à la fin donc il y à 7 ce phénomène là
de populisme monsieur erdogan joue
aujourd'hui sur de velours en s'appuyant
sur les réseaux des frères musulmans qui
sont présents dans plusieurs pays arabes
et non arabes alors que dans les pays
arabes
il a un allié le qatar deux cent
cinquante mille personnes
il a une colonie tripoli en libye et ils
cherchent à s'implanter dans le terrier
relativement isolé c'est ce qu'il est
totalement isolé laurent saint martin
les relations entre emmanuel macron
erdogan sont mauvaises depuis longtemps
est-ce qu'il a franchi une ligne rouge
le président turc en contestant la santé
mentale du président français will a
franchi une étape de plus dans
l'outrance c'est évident mais comme ça a
été très bien dit le personnage poursuit
poursuit dans son populisme et dans ses
excès là dessus avec probablement un
certain succès intérieure quand même
s'il a bien digéré non plus jusqu'à 10
sur le séparatisme et notamment les oui
mais oui mais il ne parle pas des imams
le clean il n'a jamais parlé du fond du
discours des mureaux et au contraire il
utiliser le manipule pour essayer
justement d'en faire croire que c'est un
discours anti musulman ce que totalement
l'opposé du disco islam consulaire
angers delà de la république mais bien
sûr bien sûr que tout cela participe aux
propos du producteur d'ogm est-ce qu'il
faut répondre
est-ce qu'il faut sanctionner quelqu'un
qui traite le président de la république
française de malade mental puisque c'est
à peu près ça je ne crois pas et je
crois que ça ne mérite même pas une
réponse à ce niveau là en revanche qui
est vrai c'est qu'il faut appeler à
l'apaisement comme ça a été fait par le
président de la république et ne pas
oublier que derrière tout ça il ya aussi
des diversions par rapport à un certain
nombre de problématiques diplomatiques
internationales qui sont gravissimes et
je pense notamment la situation du haut
karabagh qu'on ne peut pas évacuer comme
cela même si ça concerne 150 mille
personnes la situation est absolument
résumé erdogan soutien l'azerbaïdjan
évidemment est dans le haut karabakh et
donc il ne faudrait pas pour résumer
là-dessus faire passer l'outrance du
président turc comme étant le paravent
d'une problématique il nous faut surtout
pas oublier que celle du haut-karabakh
ces mots oui
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que la france
est une cible au delà même de macron
extrêmement symbolique la modernité
turcs sont les décombres de l'empiré
ottoman pendant cinq siècles et l empire
ottoman les ottomans était calif
c'étaient les sculpteurs notamment été
calif bon c'était le symbole de l'islam
c'est un empire et c'est un bon mustafa
kemal atatürk fait la turquie moderne la
république jacobine inspiré du modèle
français utilisent le mollet alors la
laïcité turque assez différente de la
nôtre en réalité c'est un contrôle de
l'état sur les imams mais il ya le mot
likely c'est le crois c'est une des
seules langues
on en en anglais il avait ses collard
qui n'est pas exactement laïque donc la
france a été le symbole de la modernité
de la turquie erdogan aujourd'hui un
projet explicite qui et voilà on veut
refermer une parenthèse de deux siècles
on vous rendra la turquie sont passés sa
splendeur ottomane redevenir une
puissance est évidemment dans cette
logique là où il bascule vers l'orient
la france c'est la cible c'est-à-dire
attaquer la france est bon d'un côté
c'est emmanuel macron pour un certain
nombre de mots qu emmanuel macron
hadi compris sur cette histoire en
france justement de l'à-propos du
séparatisme qui est extrêmement sensible
parce que ce sont les lycées turcs
affalé lycée où il ya des enseignants
tueur mais au delà même de tout ça il ya
aussi macron un peu le symbole comme
l'était nicolas sarkozy donc c'est assez
facile de prendre cette cible et c'est
là dessus que d'une certaine façon il
réussit au de même s'il n'ya pas des
manifestations très importantes à jouer
sur un sentiment de frustration reér de
la turquie juste un mot pour finir qui
est celui que la turquie les
négociations avec l'europe surtout point
mort et que la tequila dire qu'il n'a
pas été comme les pays candidats je vous
propose et je vous promets que je vous
donne la parole parce que je sens vous
pouvez rajouter c'est passionnant à des
éléments aase à ce débat mais on va
retrouver la ville de dallas à présent
dallas où c'est richard vers l'est qui
nous aide qui nous attend parce que
richard chroniqueur dans cette émission
suit les élections américaines pour son
quotidien le quotidien suisse le temps
on s'est posé la question de savoir si
emmanuel macron n'était pas un peu isolé
tout de même
après l'hommage à semelle pâtit sur les
sur les caricatures en disant qu'il
fallait poursuivre le combat remontrer
les caricatures on a parlé des drapeaux
français brûlés comment la presse anglo
saxonne regarde ce qui se passe en
france richard est ce que ces
agissements d'erdogan ces drapeaux
français brûlés sont condamnés est ce
que la parole présidentielle est
soutenue alors myriam j'entendais tout à
leur parler des visées politiques
intérieures et bien c'est ce que
retiennent avant tout les journaux
américains
pour eux la france et la turquie sont
des alliés au sein de l'otan qui ne
s'aiment plus du tout mais ce duel
politique
il profite avant tout aux deux
protagonistes que sont emmanuel macron
et recep erdogan et ça c'est le
washington post qui le disaient mardi
alors vu de ce côté ci de l'atlantique
de toute façon les deux hommes macro
erdogan sont dans une posture de
belligérants verbaux qui convient à leur
électorat
la veille c'est à dire lundi le new york
times avait qualifié le président
français deux défenseurs acharnés de la
laïcité un terme marc semo l'a bien dit
qu'ici aux états unis et traduit par un
mot plus envie
sécularisme il ne faut pas oublier que
la puissante amérique par ailleurs est à
la veille d'une présidentielle de tous
les dangers le 3 novembre est donc ici
la surenchère verbale c'est le quotidien
donald trump ne fait que ça donc pour le
washington post
macron comme erdogan eh bien ils sont de
bons élèves de donald trump macron à
d'évidentes motivation intérieur pour sa
rhétorique juge l'éditorialiste ishan
kachur le site politico qui est très lu
à washington s'inquiète pour sa part
quand même des années des visées de ce
duel
et il cite une universitaire selon
laquelle il est triste de voir la france
réponde à l'extrémisme par l'extrémiste
le même politique ou qu'il ya un site
européen très présent néanmoins nuance
pour eux
macron n'est pas le tenant d'une ligne
dure sur l'islam donc on voit quand même
qu'il y à plus de compréhension
la vérité est en réalité c'est qu'ici
aux états unis on pense que cette
bataille franco-turcs ne va rien changer
pour washington la turquie est un allié
beaucoup trop important la laïcité
française comme je les dis on ne la
comprend pas voir on ne la partage pas
on sait aussi que trump et erdogan font
plutôt bon ménage
autrement dit si le président sortant
est réélu le 3 novembre
c'est le sultan d'ankara qui aura
davantage mais rssi beaucoup ri cha et
bonne campagne c'est j'ose dire bonne ce
bon suivi de campagne reviendra
évidemment vers vous dans cette émission
antoine basbous
les anglo saxons les américains
comprennent pas très bien ce qui s'est
joué dans notre pays on a l'impression
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que il
faut pas accepter l'insultent de
monsieur erdogan parce que faut pas se
montrer mou il faut se montrer viril
sait il ne respecte que les hommes forts
que les hommes virils
si la france riposté par exemple
françois hollande ce matin disait il
faut remettre en cause la présence de la
turquie dans l'otan il ne faut pas que
les choses se passent comme si de rien
n'était comme monsieur erdogan c'est le
un chef d'état il peut pas insulter un
autre chef d'état sans conséquence il
faut pas se montrer mou est engagé au
moins servir de sortie ça serait
possible
c'est ce que cherche mon cher c'est
d'isoler la france est de l'affaiblir de
la montre est molle comme l'europe est
là il faut pas céder là dessus il y a
des rendez vous européens il y à des
aides européennes
il y à un processus qu'il faut
déclencher
pour que monsieur erdogan tienne sa
riposte est trop mal c'est pas le sujet
principal de la france aujourd'hui
mais il ne faut pas laisser passer parce
que monsieur erdogan revient à la charge
tous les deux jours il y à un nouveau
procès qui l'attend à la france donc il
faut pas laisser faire laisser faire il
doit être intransigeant sur les
principes et ne pas se montrer mufasa
monsieur 40 secondes pas plus longue en
couleurs ne pas laisser le problème ce
ne sont pas des mots parce que ça ne
sert à rien d'être dans la surenchère
des invectives
la question c'est effectivement de
prendre concrètement des décisions
vis-à-vis de la turquie compris de
sanctions économiques ou de remise en
cause au niveau de l'accord de l'union
douanière
le problème c'est que la france là
dessus est très isolé comme la france
est très isolé on avait vu cet été à
propos de l'incident naval au large de
la libye où on a frôlé la balle entre
bateaux turcs et ensuite à l'otan 22
pays n'ont pas suivi la faïence qui n'a
été soutenu mais toujours la même
question comment agir dans les instances
internationales où la france n'est pas
toujours majoritaire merci au cinéma on
y voit beaucoup plus clair merci antoine
basbous merci marc semo et merci laurent
saint martin d'avoir été notre grand
témoin ce soir fin de cette émission
rester avec nous parce qu après
l'allocution du président de la
république à 20h et bien vous pourrez
regarder une soirée documentaire
exceptionnel sur lcp sur un thème dans
l'actualité ô combien à la une la
laïcité et les fractures de la gauche
française documentaire signé thomas
legrand très belle soirée à vous
[Musique]